hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher one of the mathematicians and
educators I love and respect most is Dan
Finkel it talks about the centrality of
playfulness in mathematics now I think
it's really vital to to get at that idea
because so much of mathematics yes does
have real practical applications out in
the real world solves problems that
really we really want how to build a
bridge or work out how much money you're
gonna need to save to purchase certain
item in the future but vast swathes of
mathematical thinking are not designed
to solve a particular problem they are
just you know fruits of people playing
around with patterns and say I wonder
what happens if we can do this to the
numbers or I wonder what will emerge if
we set these rules and just see what
happens right for me that playfulness
and willingness to say okay well let's
just set up some experimental rules that
don't necessarily have an attachment to
the real world and see what happens for
me those are important to developing
that conceptual understanding because
when people have a sense of mathematics
is just for solving problems and is just
for I have some information I need to
put them together in some way to get an
answer out they sort of robbed
themselves of the real goal which is
understanding you know we sort of saw
obsessed with getting from point A to
point B and then finishing we don't say
okay let's just stop and look around and
explore this environment and see if
we're inquisitive what can we understand
about the patterns that are here so much
about for example something as simple as
prime numbers which you know it takes
quite a while to get to the practical
applications now of yes all modern
cryptography and the entire internet and
economy are built on our ability to say
prime numbers are really easy to
multiply together really hard to get out
of the big enormous number that emerges
out of them that takes a long time to
get to but playing with the patterns in
the prime numbers is something that can
be enjoyable and something that can hook
students into that mathematical
reasoning before they even get to the
practical situations in context that
those prime numbers help us to solve so
I think that again it's about reaching
down to be able to play with a scenario
and say there's understanding that can
be
gained here without reference to okay
there's a particular problem I want to
solve and I think giving students that
ability and that time that capacity is
really important to cultivating their
curiosity
[Music]